foreign
yeah oh my God
oh my God
that was beautiful
that is
that is the type of forced fraudulent
trout response
that will Propel this whole show
is there a nice crowd who did a Show
recently was 10 guys been yelling out
the entire night through every
comedian's act yelling stuff like
titties
you know helpful stuff
they eventually threw them out and
they're out in the hallway arguing with
the bouncer and it got really heated and
little sky in the group was right in the
bouncer's face like yeah man lay a hand
on me I dare you I'm a lawyer I can sue
you
he actually said that I'm a lawyer I can
sue you
because as you know only lawyers can sue
people
he's so lucky he had that job
otherwise man yeah man lay hand on me
you'd be crazy not too
you will get away with it
I work at a magic shop
sadly I'm not a lawyer
all lawsuits are just lawyers suing
people who punch them in the face
I'd like to see that trial
well you're on it all started when I
felt the knee TL titties out for 20
straight minutes
well this is going to be a short one
I find in favor of anyone who punched
you in the face
oh
titties
I was talking to Chris Rock the other
day not to name drop and he said I told
him I was doing a special he goes start
out with a really solid joke and it
seems that's what I've done
let's walk around my neighborhood walk
past a girl scouts selling cookies at a
table with her mom next door I walk
close to the table I saw the Girl Scout
was signing autographs for people
so I was like oh you movie star her
mom's like her pictures on the box
her picture was on the box
I'd never seen this before
I freaked out
then I got a little competitive
I was like well the only reason I ask is
I'm actually a movie star
I don't know what movies you've seen at
your young age little Janie but I bet
you saw one called Pootie Tang
[Applause]
[Music]
you remember the guy in the car
you're talking to him
what about the wrestler did you see that
one little Jenny yeah I got to go to the
Venice film festival for the premiere
huh
I mean they made me pay my own way but
when I got there they let me watch a
movie
yeah 3 300 flight
700 for a talks yeah yeah
anyway give me a box of Samoas make it
out the top
good to be back on stage at a real venue
Comics has been doing some weird gigs
over this pandemic
used to be a get a text from a cog be
like have you done that new club in St
Louis did they put you up in a nice
hotel
now it's like have you done that fire
escape show on Staten Island
how many hand washing stations today
been tested for covet like 38 times
at some point I realized it's something
to do
oh this is an activity isn't it
this should be in timeout New York's
free stuff to do this week
I'd hear about a testing site that had
an hour away it'll be like all right
that'll work
so I can find one with a two-hour wait
try to make it a social event called my
friend Phil up I go Phil let's go get
tested together
be great we'll walk six feet apart stand
in line six feet apart be a great covet
hang
it's like Todd I don't need to get
tested I've been quarantining and also I
need to go to the Apple Store
you can do both
reminds me of the time I was in solitary
confinement needed to go to Supercuts
want to get a Cova test and they're
sitting on a swab each nostril for 10
seconds this is the way she counted one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
he's like you know I'm a busy guy but I
did block off the full 20 seconds
wasn't looking for express service on
this
I'd hate to get stitches from you
I'm going to give you 10 stitches one
two nine ten get out of here
[Applause]
I just freed up some time in your day to
show off your gaping wounds
people got mad if you got the vaccine
too soon
you hear these conversations you get
vaccinated yeah oh how'd that happen
I have asthma oh you have asthma
that's interesting
I'm saying I've known you for two hours
you've never mentioned that you have
asthma
got mine a little early got my sticker
saying I got vaccinated posted on
Instagram thought people would be happy
for me somewhere
others are like I want to know how you
got that vaccine
then someone else writing yeah I was
about to ask them that myself
then the third person be like you guys
both beat me to the punch on this one
how do you get that Jab
so I calm down fellas I'm about to post
a screenshot of my medical records
it is your business
it's really good about wearing my mask
cutting a few actual altercations with
anti-masters
cannot believe how Brave I was
I'd be at Bed Bath and Beyond but like
hey you
I'm talking to you 17 year old stock
clerk
see the guy by the salad spinners no
mask get them
yeah grab that set of carving knives
that's a big dude
you're a little guy
and I'm headed for the exit
I'm not even gonna pay for these scrub
daddies
I was in Burlington Vermont got into a
taxi and I saw the driver didn't have a
mask on I said you have a mask you can
put on he's like I do but you're not
gonna like it
please pull out the hilarious novelty
Mass
this guy pulls on a mask and says Biden
is as useless as his mask
oh you got him
powerful stuff
he's going to be sad if he ever reads
that if he's straddling your rear view
mirror
then the guy said this new variant it's
just bronchitis
that's what my doctor told me
I was your doctor adjusting your back
while he told you that
[Applause]
coming out
subtle Chiropractic reference
always brings the house down
good year for doctors to be on TV Sanjay
Gupta oh my God they put that guy to
work
especially early on the pandemic he'd be
on CNN like hi everyone I'm Sanjay Gupta
I'm a neurosurgeon and today I'm going
to teach you how to sanitize a
nutrigrain bar
foreign
I do brain surgery
I could be doing brain surgery right now
in fact someone isn't getting brain
surgery
because I'm standing here with a tub of
Clorox wipes about to teach you how to
do something you don't actually need to
do
but more on that in eight months
[Music]
to learn how to cook during the pandemic
went on Tick Tock for recipes
every recipe on Tick Tock is speed
oriented
if you want to make a 25 second
breakfast
start the clock
I started to embrace the idea of cooking
but then there's always that ingredient
deal breaker
I'd be watching the chef on the screen
like oh come on man you think I have
rice vinegar
you know I don't have rice vinegar
look at me you know I don't have
three people in the world have rice
vinegar you and your two roommates
foreign
how lazy it was about cooking I'd read
the directions on a microwave burrito be
like heat on high for one minute then
flip over
[Applause]
I didn't go to Le court on Blue Culinary
Academy
I'm gonna see if I can slam this out in
one step
no basting
glad we're eating out again I've had
some great exchanges with waiters and
waitresses over the years There's an
actual exchange act with a waiter and an
Italian restaurant in New York City not
too long ago
high is it possible to get a decaf
espresso you're the worst
I don't mean to be all lawyerly but that
was a yes or no question
but if you want to go with you're the
worst that works fine
anyway give me a decaf espresso with
a big spoon of ketchup and
now I'm really bad
I was in a diner in Oklahoma
I ordered a salad and she goes what kind
of dressing I said Italian she leaned
and whispered something to me but I
didn't understand her go what's that she
was like
what's not good
the Italian dressing
it's not good
what's not good about it
it's not that Tangy
[Applause]
maybe you and I have different standards
for tank
which dressing should I get
I'd go a thousand island
I don't like Thousand Islands
I'll have the Italian
[Applause]
are you sure it's not good
well part of it's not good don't you
understand
we'll end that one right there
was like four points I could have gotten
out of that joke and I just kept going
felt so comfortable with you guys
doing really good before the pandemic
started taking a pilates class
consisted of me and three women who knew
how to do Pilates
the instructor always had to make
adjustment check all right let's do that
thing when we hang from a bar and do
jumping jacks and sit-ups at the same
time
Todd here's some crayons
why don't you mark up the wall for me
draw an owl for me
big owl with a lot of detail
all right ladies I'm gonna stand on our
hands and put 100 pound weights on the
balls of your feet Todd I don't know
download a Scrabble app
thank you
or leave yeah why don't you leave
that idea best
walking's good exercise walk on at air
yes I see your T-shirt it says I heart
Pilates
hit the road
Chicago is pretty cool City huh
[Applause]
that was I took a pandering course
earlier
and they said to say that on stage
how much is the house here
what's that nine nine one nine dollars
oh my God
note to self
talk to someone else
Pharma just sold in New York City bought
by a hedge fund manager 238 million
dollars twenty four thousand square feet
if I had a 24 000 square foot apartment
New York I'd still be telling people
from out of town I'm not really set up
for guests
yeah it's just a one bedroom apartment
with 53 home offices
foreign
yeah you're welcome to crash but you'd
be sleeping with your head on a fax
machine
the upkeep must be ridiculous on that
place you'd be at home I only want to go
to the movies today I'd love to we
really need to go to Bed Bath and Beyond
by 35 000 Swiffer sheets
I can't even imagine a 24 000 square
foot apartment my apartment is 800
square feet and I'm a celebrity
to have to become a hedge from did you
get a bigger place or worse than that
find out what a hedge fund manager is
again
tried like 500 times
people start explaining to me you know
it's not going to happen
I'll try again in six weeks
everything's expensive in New York I
want to buy new glasses eyeglasses went
to the boutique place look how much
these glasses the guy said they're a
thousand dollars
I was like oh that's kind of expensive
he's like well think of it this way
you'll have them for three years
a dollar a day foreign
it sounds more expensive
these glasses or anything you have to
give me a dollar a day every day for
three years
I'll be like wow that is a pricey pair
of glasses
I'm doing the math in my head I'd say
that's roughly one thousand dollars
why don't I take a thousand dollars by
two pairs of 200 glasses and also a
round trip ticket to Barcelona
I'm glad we're traveling again
a few years ago I went to Bangkok
almost didn't go saw a video on YouTube
called the scams of Bangkok
this dude was a little paranoid he's
like if you go to a museum and you see
someone smiling total scam
if you go to a restaurant they have
noodles on the menu your identity's just
been stolen
if you show up at your hotel there's a
front desk call Interpol
classic flim flap
foreign
work
what do you think
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going
what's your name
what do you do Chris
holy
I don't think I want to do crowd work
tonight
design engineer what does that mean
okay
I'm in the business I get this
I was just gonna how great these recess
lights are tonight
it's good talking to you Chris
[Music]
[Applause]
we just took a recess from being funny
for a while
[Applause]
I pulled that one out huh
and trying out airbnbs on the road you
got to read those listings very closely
they always start out good it's like on
a tree-lined street close to shops and
restaurants oh I like that you'll have
the whole place yourself oh I like that
I let my neighbor stores guns in my
linen closet
yeah not sure how I feel about that
so he might pop in from time to time
definitely don't like that
but don't worry he has a key ooh that
makes me worry
also there's a great home theater system
you're not allowed to use it stay out of
the kitchen
and there's a python under the sofa
you must feed him 15 times a day
but to reiterate you'll have the whole
place yourself
close to shops and restaurants
I always get nervous booking an Airbnb
because my pictures in my profile
I know the hosts are normally going oh
my God honey
look at that you're not going to believe
who's sleeping in our attic tonight
I'll give you a clue small but pivotal
role in pootie time
foreign
yeah he can't afford a hotel I guess not
let's get the good pillows out for him
I uh stayed a hotel in Los Angeles
and when I got back I realized I left my
toiletry back at the hotel in Los
Angeles and it was a really nice one
sent to me by the Cartoon Network had
cartoons all over it
I wanted it back I called up the hotel I
got I was in room 318 I left my toiletry
back it's got cartoons all over it
I was like oh yeah we found that
I was like great can I get it back he's
like can you describe the cartoons
did you think I was calling you on the
off chance
that someone left behind the toiletry
bag with cartoons on it
like I'm in the market for one don't
know where to find one so I'm calling
hotels all day long
hoping for a miracle
maybe got an anonymous tip
some guy comes up to me in an alley Town
don't ask who I am but
if you're in the market for half a
bottle of dandruff shampoo and
five Dusty viagras
call this hotel time in room 318.
you left your toiletry bag it's got
cartoons all over it what kind of
cartoons they'll never ask you that
why would they ask you that
'd be crazy to ask you that
straight clap there
took an Uber in the Midwest and at the
end of the ride the driver said sir I
owe you an apology I was like for what
he goes I'm sorry I didn't talk during
the trip
I really like to focus on my driving
it's like well other apologies I've been
waiting 35 years for
this guy hits me with the most
unnecessary apology
so like sir if you're apologizing for
not making me talk to a stranger for an
hour and a half
guess what all's forgiven
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe it doesn't always go that way
maybe sometimes like Sarah won't
apologized for not talking during the
trip yeah what was with that man
you see me back here all lonesome
just a man in his French horn
[Music]
I played the French horn in Middle
School
so I was able to nail that tone
at least the guy apologized oh that was
nice I like apologies
I even like shitty apologies
my favorite shitty apology is the
convenient apology
or someone only apologizes because they
ran into you
it's always something that happened a
long time ago it's like hey Todd I'm
glad I ran into you man I
remember we were at that party recently
that's 1991.
I got a little drunk you got really
drunk
I said a few things I should have said
you said a lot of things you shouldn't
assume I think I beat the shadow you did
beat the
anyway I just want to say I'm sorry
well I appreciate that Scott to think
this would have happened if I went to my
usual frozen yogurt shop
let's do some more crowd work
whoa
calm down seven o'clock show
what's your name
Brana b-r-e-n-n-a
what do you do Brianna
holy you got any stories
you really
in the car
the car you were driving in
you looked outside and there was a bear
in the car
foreign
[Music]
that you weren't looking outside
I looked outside inside the car
that's a good story
cut that one
cutting room floor
did you how did you react to the bear
there you go
you know poor bears not to open doors
foreign
[Music]
save that one also
he's talking a guy in the audience asked
him what he did for a living he goes I'm
a cabinet salesman
I was like do you like it he's like love
it
I was like what do you love about being
a cabinet sales and because I like
having dinner with my customers
oh I didn't know that was a wine and
dine situation
well Todd your cabinets are all
installed what do you think I love them
I'll put my Cocoa Puffs in there really
soon
well Todd now that they're all installed
I guess it's Bistro time right
time for the traditional post cabinet
installation
celebratory dinner
what are you hankering for
I'm sorry I'm having dinner with the
guys who steam clean my drapes
it's been quite a day breakfast with my
exterminator
happy hour drinks with my plumber
you know maybe you can have lunch
tomorrow you know what I'm going to
apple picking with the guys who Greek
her out of my bathroom top
this is a true story I was in New
Orleans on tour about six months ago and
I started that joke I said yeah I met
this guy was a cabin sales and this guy
yells out that was me
I looked down it was him
[Music]
[Applause]
what a thrill for that dude man
imagine sitting there and I do a joke
about you
it's unbelievable
I'm so happy for the guy
that might happen with the bear story
I still don't I didn't follow that story
I still don't know where the bear was
like if it was in the car why would you
lock the door
I'm gonna be up all night with this one
I think we like calling people
yeah I don't know if it's inside or
outside there
yeah she locked the door yeah
from the locked it from the outside I
think
but the Bears inside
I guess we'll never know
I uh my printer broke recently sorry
to bomb you out
the light flash it said paper jam so I
called a printer tech support I go have
a paper jam the guy's like paper jam huh
let me go do a little research
and paper jams
did I lay a new term on you
isn't that the problem you make fun of
at the call center
like the phone rings like oh I wonder if
there's gonna be a paper jam
it's like calling up a steakhouse and
asking if they know about baked potatoes
it's like calling me up and asking me if
I know about standing ovations
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God
I can't believe you applauded it then
I feel so guilty
no I can I was being a dick I can be a
dick sometimes
I really like feeling intellectually
Superior I was at a bar in Austin Texas
and the guy next to me was talking to
the bartender and he goes I like the
last drink he made me more better than
this one
I was like oh
we got ourselves a dum-dum
a full 30 seconds passes
the guy turns to me he's like did I just
say more better
it's like how do you make that mistake
and then catch that mistake
I liked it more better when you didn't
know how to talk
got that more better joke working
a month ago that was dead in the water
then come here and it's such a
successful moment in the show
that was my bear story
[Applause]
I had a beard for a while
then I got a girlfriend who doesn't like
beards and she was really subtle about
it
she'd say things like oh you have a
beard huh
some of my friends like guys with beards
I was like oh that's weird some of my
friends like when people say things
directly
this is a true story I got an audition
for that show billions and I told her
about it she's like do you have to shave
for your audition
only question she had about the other
shave for it
no it's I don't have to shave for it
it's an audition it's not like they're
going to watch my tape and go oh my God
he's perfect
but this character's clean shaven
there's no easy fix for this
we'll go with Daniel Day-Lewis
protection
my girlfriend's from Rural Oregon and
she wanted to go camping I was like I
don't know about camping
she's like do you even know how to put
up a tent I was like no I don't she's
like that's a good skill to have
what if there's an emergency and I'm
incapacitated
never thought of that
whenever I've thought of emergencies
that one's not come up
9-1-1 what's your emergency my
girlfriend was attacked by a bear sir
calm down do you know how to assemble a
tent
I was hoping you'd send medical
attention
sir was sending five REI employees
I'll make some s'mores and hang tight
till they get there
I don't know anything about sports my
girlfriend knows more about sports than
I do and I actually asked her this
question I go do you stand up or lie
down on a snowboard
like three months ago she just stopped
laughing 10 minutes ago
I've never heard him laugh this loud in
my life
I was like baby laugh at my amazing
jokes not my perfectly reasonable
questions
gotta look for red flags and
relationships I like looking for red
flags in other people's relationships
especially before they even have one
that's the best
someone's all excited about a potential
new romance they talk to me I'd bum them
out it's great
this friend of mine was going on a first
day like where are you going she's gonna
meet at a bar tomorrow night at 10
o'clock 10 o'clock ooh red flag
foreign
he works at a hospital ooh second red
flag
he's a highly respected surgeon ooh
third red flag
he's a huge fan of your comedy this guy
sounds horrible
I got an email from my doctor's office
telling me my doctor is becoming
something called a concierge doctor
meaning there's a twenty three hundred
dollar annual fee just to see her and I
still have to pay for all the
appointments email said it's a great
program you get a special phone number
where you can text your doctor 24 hours
a day a special phone number you mean
the doctor's phone number
I can text her 24 hours a day okay dear
doctor
[Music]
sorry to bother you at 4am on your
burner phone
but I have a really important question
can I take a third Advil
I employ you to write back before five
my head is pounding
sorry I'd find a good doctor hardest
doctor to find is a therapist
one of my insurance companies website
looking for a therapist I had a list of
therapists who take the insurance and
you can sort them by distance
seemed like a weird way to find a
therapist that's the way I find a dry
cleaner
can't imagine that someone's like I'm
really depressed but if you make me walk
more than two minutes
for excellent care
I'll be really really depressed
can you imagine ending up with that
therapist you found sorting by distance
I'd be at that first appointment Todd I
got to ask you how did you find me
oh your office is in my building
I live directly upstairs
I woke up 11 seconds ago
I thought you look familiar Todd
probably seen in the hallway I was also
in pootie tank yeah that was it
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never seen you in the hallway
was your small but pivotal roll and pity
time
that's a weird word to mispronounce
hey you said pootie tag wrong
okay
you got the joke
therapists have websites now I saw a
therapist's website and linked to his
Twitter page it's like oh do you have
tour dates and merch also
I clicked on this guy's Twitter page I
saw he followed a bunch of comedians I
was like oh not going to this guy
I don't want a comedy nerd as my
therapist
I'll be at the appointment crime I was
out dog I feel awful what should I do
well Todd are you thought of doing
something nice for someone else maybe
that'll make you feel better like what I
don't know why don't you hook me up with
Bill Burr tickets
I don't know if that's going to help doc
didn't help when I gave you Patton
Oswald's email address
and you gotta stop writing too
he's not going to read that script
I read somewhere that the most marked up
bottle of wine on a restaurant's wine
list is the second cheapest reason I do
that has got to be on a day too
embarrassed about the cheapest wine
picks the second cheapest and gets
destroyed
foreign
the best thing I've ever read my entire
life
it's like who can we screw over here at
the restaurant how about a guy looking
for love who's also on a budget
that's why I hired you PJ
you're an idea man
sees Filipino Noir cost us a dollar
fifty let's go 600 on this one
but I love cooking shows and shows about
travel and stuff like that I was
actually on the Seth Meyers show Once
years ago and the other guest was
Anthony Bourdain I got to meet him real
briefly and I'm glad it was a brief
meeting because I don't want to be
backstage trading Road stories with
Anthony Bourdain
his would be like yeah I remember once I
was in South America got bitten by a
snake while I was trying to eat its
small intestine
oh you know I was once at a Hampton Inn
in Little Rock
and they ran out of Captain Crunch at
the breakfast buffet
poor guy must have had annoying fans
when you're traveling food expert
people running up to you on the street
Anthony here's the deal I'm going to
Malaysia and I love turkey burgers
thank you
Anthony best Rice Krispie Treat in
Paraguay let's hear it
Anthony I'm going to Dusseldorf and I
love empanadas
I need your top off
I like that show Chopped that's a great
show four chefs compete for a ten
thousand dollar prize my favorite part
about that show is none of the chefs
have a realistic grasp of what you can
buy for ten thousand dollars
I was like Chef what are you gonna do if
you win the ten thousand dollars well
I've always wanted to travel around the
world for a year
flying first class everywhere
oh you can do that for another 1.3
million dollars
here's what you're going to fly first
class to Cleveland
take a mega bus to Columbus
fly back premium economy from Columbus
with a five hour layover in Cleveland
then you're out of money
Chef what are you gonna do if you win
ten thousand dollars we'll have six
brothers that left to buy them eat your
Rolls-Royce
here's what you're going to do you're
gonna buy three decent skateboards
then you make a little sign up sheet
your brothers can take turns
Chef what are you doing the ten thousand
dollars I think it'd be great to buy my
mom a house
that'd be the greatest find your mom a
sweet ten thousand dollar house
here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna buy yourself an updated
food processor
then the best wooden spoon
then you can make your mom some dip and
she can enjoy it in the house she
currently lives in
not the ten thousand dollar before taxes
dream house
also known as a three thousand dollar
house
also known as a used minivan
it's fun being a comedian work at night
have all day to have some weird days
had a weird day recently went to the
podiatrist then I adopted a kitten
that was my to-do list for a Tuesday
it was great I was at the podiatrist
office stretched out looking down on my
little toes I was like oh
I can't imagine anything cuter than that
40 minutes later holy what was I
thinking
finally found something cuter than my
little toes
little baby kitty cat
it's fun being a new cat owner get to
buy her stuff I was on Amazon looking at
cat treats found the brand of cat treat
there's a bunch of reviews next to it
saw there was a one star review I was
like oh
I gotta read a one-star review of a cat
treat
this was the entire review my cat didn't
like this
guys at his keyboard I'm going to keep
this lean and mean
my captain like this
I could just see that guy at home hey
Pockets come here
got some new treats here to try what do
you think oh you don't like them well
don't worry Daddy will bankrupt the
company
what just try a different brand don't be
so petty
you don't be so polite Pockets I'm going
to crush them
made mistake of getting a kitten instead
of an adult cat that's a mistake she's
adorable but my God I don't know who's
in for she attacks me while I'm trying
to sleep
it's gotten so bad I've actually checked
into hotels
I've checked into the closest hotel in
my apartment three different times to
get some sleep
probably five thousand dollars worth of
hotels
it's a great check in though you walk in
no bags bleeding
so you're here for business sir no
actually a kid and attack me
oh where are you coming in from look
outside
see that building 50 feet away see that
light on the seventh floor see that
kitten in the window
yeah the one drinking a glass of rose
smoking a cigarette one of those long
holders
oh she's holding up a sign Todd Berry is
overrated
where does a kitty learn that word
it's incomprehensible
supposed to brush my cat's teeth that
was sprung on they recently bought a vet
you got to start brushing your teeth I
was like okay I uh I wouldn't have
gotten the cat
just saying had I known I would have
considered it for one second
that's too late I love her
so I went on YouTube looking for
tutorials how to brush your cat's teeth
thought there might be one or two
there's thousands of them
all the same none of them are helpful
they're all like here's how you brush
your cat's teeth first start out with
the world's most relaxed cat
you got that no I don't got that
shockingly I do not have that
Place her carefully on this table
specifically designed to examine animals
you can get one at your local veterinary
supply store for six thousand dollars
now take the toothbrush and toothpaste
out Watch What Happens oh my God she
took it from my hand
he's taking the cap off the toothpaste
she's brushing her own teeth
where'd you get a water pick baby
snuck off the Target and bought a water
pack
supposed to schedule play time with the
cat I don't know you're supposed to do
that
I don't want to play with my cat I'll
watch shark attack with my cat
we'll call that playing
come here baby sit in my lap we're gonna
apply scratch scratch scratch 500
000 for two percent equity Ram yeah
that's
all right yes bad valuation baby yeah
they better have some sales
the apartment I live in charges me fifty
dollars a month because of a cat
it's like a little spiteful pet fee they
have
remember being in the leasing office
Simon Elise God's like so it's just you
in the apartment yeah just me and my cat
also it's not just you in the park
there's also something this big living
there
yeah she's the size of my toaster
you have a toaster
[Applause]
you gotta come clean with me my man
all right I have a couple of spoons also
okay we're gonna go 50 of the cat 30 for
the toaster eight bucks each for the
spoons
I can make that joke last 19 hours if I
wanted to
think of all the objects I didn't
mention
foreign
cafes now coffee shops with cats roaming
around in them they're great
I went to one in New Orleans the only
thing better going to Cat Cafe going to
a cat cafe alone
the only thing better going to a cat
cafe alone showing up and being the only
customer at the Cat Cafe
it's just me and 150 cats
I was just walking around like I was the
king
tell me about the gray one
seems a bit Moody for a domestic
Shorthair
why is the Tabby not playing with the
Ragamuffin they should be friends
let's try a coffee Mmm delicious
coffee always tastes best when you're
drinking your seven litter boxes
[Applause]
that's a lot of cat jokes huh
let's change the subject shall we
that's my cat
that's a little perch that's suction cup
to the uh window and sometimes the
suction cup comes undone and
I don't fix it for a while
her name's Michaeline she's a foreign
correspondent for Al Jazeera
close-up of the face
here let me show you
that's her face I hope you can't tell
where I live based on that
now you're saying Todd how we know
that's really your cat
boom
oh
same cat as you just looked at
that's me
happy
miserable
happy miserable
oh that's me and Slash
[Applause]
[Music]
that slash
that's me that's slash slash candle my
show in London
came straight from the airport
hi friends I've known 20 years who has
to be on my guest list and don't show up
slash is like we're going to clear
customs and head right over
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man I can't show this one in New York
as people get mad I have a washer and
dryer in my apartment
it's like I'm a celebrity of course I do
oh that is the
front right side of my couch
it's a fancy couch it's got exposed wood
not sure what that is probably a million
dollar contract or something
that's the rear ride of my couch
she's got more work to do on that one
oh that's me with Lars from Metallica
me that's Lars
me Lars
came to my show in Northern California
look how happy he is
here you know what
[Applause]
you saw that guy walking down the street
with that smile he'd be like did you
just go to a Todd Berry show
oh that's the front left of my couch
someone came up to me after a Show
recently she's like you know you should
get scratching posts
you mean they have special posts I think
oh my God
I have 13 scratching posts
that's the rear left of my cat
that's a speaker that fell over six
months ago
in order to fix that I'd have to lean
down and put it back up right
foreign
[Applause]
this is me giving a master class in how
to play it cool
thank you very much folks have a good
evening
thank you very much
thank you
oh look at this look at this look at
this look at this yeah yeah
thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks a lot
all right
[Music]
[Applause]